المحكمة تبدي أسفها لما حصلت للأساتذة المحامين
بسبب الحادثين اللذين
تعرضوا لها لا مانعة لقراءة سورة الفاتحة.
حاول تهديده مرة تلو أخرى.
قتلوا زملائه زميلا بعد آخر.
لن يجدي معه الترغيب والترهيب لأنه يدافع عن
قضية وطن لأنه يدافع عن أسد العراق ورئيسها.
لأنه يدافع عن آخر عمود تستند عليه الدولة
العراقية.
وعندما يسقط ستنهار الدولة بأكملها.
فما هي وظيفته؟ وكيف أداها؟ كانت وظيفته هي
الدفاع عن صدام حسين.
فهو محام. والمحامي الحقيقي هو من يدافع عن
الحق ويقف مع المظلوم أينما كان.
خميس العبيدي هو محام عراقي انضم للجنة الدفاع
عن صدام.
اللجنة مكونة من العديد من المحامين من الرجال
والنساء.
الجيش الأمريكي يخطط لاغتيال محامي صدام
ورفاقه لعدم رضوخه لأوامر المحتل.
المحامية اللبنانية بشرى خليل أحد أعضاء فريق
الدفاع عن صدام تبلغ زملائها أنهم مستهدفون من
الجيش الأمريكي وعملائه في الداخل، خصوصا وأن
المحكمة رفعت عنهم الحراسة الأمنية وسبق لها
شخصيا أن تلقت تهديدات بالقتل عبر الهاتف.
خميس العبيدي يتم تهديده أيضا مثل زملائه لكن
الذي يخاف وينحرف عن طريقه.
مسلحون يغتالون عادل محمد عباس محامي طه ياسين
رمضان نائب الرئيس العراقي فيما أصيب زميله
المحامي ثامر حمود هادي محامي برزان التكريتي
الاخ غير الشقيق لصدام حسين عندما هاجمه مسلحون
مجهولون في بغداد.
وصل التهديد الحقيقي الأول وسقط أحد أعضاء
لجنة الدفاع.
فما هو رد العبيدي وبقية اللجنة؟ اغتيال عادل
عباس زاد العبيدي وزملائه إصرارا ليكملوا
وظيفتهم فذلك يعني أنهم في الطريق السليم.
سعدون الجنابي محامي عواد حمد البندر رئيس
محكمة الثورة في عهد صدام حسين يتم خطفه من
مكتبه في حي الشعب ببغداد ثم يتم اغتياله.
العبيدي وزملاؤه لا يزالون يمارسون مهنتهم رغم
كل ما جرى.
ومع أن العبيدي ظل معارضا لعمليتي القتل
السابقتين لمحامي الدفاع وعدم وجود تدابير
أمنية له ولزملائه، ومع ذلك فقد اختار
الاستمرار في العيش في العاصمة العراقية.
في الحادي والعشرين من يونيو عام ألفين وستة
وقبل المرحلة الأخيرة من محاكمة صدام حسين
الساعة تشير إلى السابعة صباحا، وعلى أيدي
رجال يرتدون زي الشرطة العراقية، اختطف العبيدي
من منزله في حي الأعظمية في بغداد.
وبعد ذلك تم العثور على جثة العبيدي مضرجة
بالدماء ومصابة بأعيرة نارية متعددة بالقرب من
مدينة الصدر في مشهد قاس وحزين.
وقال كبير محاميي الدفاع عن صدام خليل الدليمي
إن ذلك كان لمحاولة تخويف فريق الدفاع عن صدام،
حيث اتهم وزارة الداخلية التي تدعم فرق الموت
التي تنتحل شخصية الشرطة العراقية ردة فعل صدام
ورفاقه. دفعت وفاة العبيدي صدام حسين مع
المتهمين السبعة الآخرين إلى الإضراب عن الطعام
بنية الاستمرار حتى يتم توفير الحماية الدولية
لفريق الدفاع
صابر المضربين عن الطعام احتجاجا على.
على طريقة المعاملة منكم ومن الأسياد.
ومع ذلك، صرح كبير المدعين في المحكمة جعفر
الموسوي سنستمر في المحاكمة ولن يردع، بينما
دعت منظمة العفو الدولية إلى إجراء تحقيق في
الحادث، لم تثني التهديدات خميس العبيدي عن
الدفاع عن صدام.
وعندما لم يستطع الأعداء تغيير موقفه قتلوه
ليزيح به عن طريقهم.
فهل كان اغتيال العبيدي لإخفاء أشياء كان
يعلمها عن جرائم المحاكمة؟